well another year another season of Game
of Thrones has come to a close now it's
time to talk about that funny thing as
this season of Game of Thrones season 6
was going on I was like it's kind of
like season 5 is not gonna be my
favorite season nothing's really blowing
me away
hold the door thing that this [ __ ] was a
good moment admittedly so I was kind of
feeling like this show is losing steam
in the last two episodes of this season
happened and gave us some of the best
wrap-up ever it goes to show you for a
show if this shows going for a long game
have some great wrap-up this season did
just that if you couldn't tell by the
title I'm not going to talk about
everything that happened in season 6 I
might reference a few things but all in
all I want to talk about the finale
because the finale is the finale and the
finale finale the [ __ ] finale gonna
give you a solid spoiler warning though
if you haven't watched season 6 of Game
of Thrones or the finale of season 6
make sure you've seen all of season 6
before you watch this video but we can't
talk about the finale without talking
about the second to the last episode
Battle of the bastards going to touch on
that briefly because holy [ __ ] Ramsay
Bolton was a [ __ ] twit and that little
moose knuckle got what he deserved he's
taking over Winterfell he killed the
Roose the ruse is no longer loose in the
Battle of the bastards easily the
coolest field battle we have seen yet in
Game of Thrones that [ __ ] was intense it
was great
after Rickon died of cards like dude
Rick on zig-zag dude Juke do something
no straight line I was like yeah
Ramsay's gonna he's dead sure enough
Rickon stark got shot by Ramsay Bolton
and now like Jon Snow's just pissed
cuz he's his brother too or is he as
though now he's gonna go and he's gonna
get revenge sure enough man I mean after
the battle goes down it's just intense
[ __ ] great stuff everything from the
execution of them like the Ramsay's guys
like spearing and closing in on Jon
Snow's guys you're like you're all toast
unless a miracle happens I'll here comes
Peter Baelish with Sansa and the Tully's
in their army they say the day and then
Ramsay Bolton's tied to a chair and he
starved of dogs for seven days and just
that's just a lesson right there don't
starve your puppy and sauce is just
looking at him and just his dog just eat
his face and Ramsay Bolton's now dead
and we're all happy Ramsay was a [ __ ]
stain dude he just had to go you just
like when a villain is so villainous he
just has to die horribly right frankly
he's not horribly enough I wanted to see
all of it I wanted to see his guts and
entrails just spell out and now we come
to the finale and he knew from last week
as I own next week the trial
Cersei Lannister right the trial to
Cersei Lannister is getting ready for
her trial so you think she's dressing up
nice so yeah well she is dressing up
nice but not for the trial pink gorilla
grodd comes in it just keeps Tommen at
bay in his room and you're like but it's
what's going on long story short the
little Oliver Twist kids killed grand
maester pycelle and lots of Lannister
that paralyze them he's crawling it's
like holy [ __ ] there is a bunch of
wildfire with this candle that's burning
down you're like oh alright everyone in
the red cape that's like all of the
Tyrells except Granny Tyrell and all of
the religious zealots which for two
years to two seasons I've been like can
those religious zealot [ __ ] just
die already for me they were just
bogging down the entire show I'm like
dude just kill them somehow
three to one candle hits the wildfire
all of it the red keep Shaboom the
religious [ __ ] twits the tyrell digit
almonds wife archery Tyrells gone a
bunch of folks got eradicated and Cersei
just that it happened because she's like
you know what screw this [ __ ] Tommy's
looking at it and horror he's like oh my
god that oh my god which is what I've
been thinking for about a year now like
say what you want about Joffrey he never
would have let those [ __ ] take over
his city he'd have been like oh you're
keeping who and you're keeping what
you're torturing who yeah you're all
toast it's like Tom and just didn't have
enough balls like Joffrey did too much
Tom and didn't do enough somewhere in
the middle is somewhere were effective
lies and then the great shocker Tommen
takes off his crown who's like you know
what goodbye and when all of it went up
and so it just did Cersei blew everybody
up and my words out of my mouth I was
like good for her undeniably guys
everyone can agree there is a word to
describe Cersei Lannister and it is [ __ ]
yeah I know everyone in America is like
but I have gone through the rolodex of
swear words and slurs and I'm like
[ __ ] no [ __ ] no douchebag no no no
[ __ ] the word and when a show can get
me to go you know what good for her too
that character I just I just think
that's great I'm just so surprised that
this show brought me answer I've never
so completely been a Cersei side as much
as I was in the finale of this season
right down to the part where she's
torturing that bad mortis
had with the belly of the latest eating
shame ding shame that lady torturing the
[ __ ] out of her and I'm like good job
sirs day we're friends right now
next season probably not so much Cersei
Lannister is a great villain she's
effective she's an [ __ ] and I just I
love to see her operate but I hate to
love her or love to hate her I don't
know which one but it's just one of the
two and now tom is dead which is great
because I was like line of succession
because the Fernan tight over this whole
year I'm like Tom and sister got killed
by the Dornish folks and nothing ever
played into that they're like alright
funeral and there's a whole time I was
like are you guys ever gonna is anything
gonna happen for that what what was the
point of that line a succession was the
point because she would be next in line
to actually rule the Seven Kingdoms but
now I'm like don't cert holy [ __ ] she's
gonna be queen she is at the end of the
episode she gets her crown and you're
like okay if it the kids were the thing
grounding her she was like you know what
I want to be a dick to everything but my
kids just they come first they're my
love for them supersedes my wrath and
rage for everything else now she doesn't
have anything now she's gonna fight for
Cersei and something tells me that
Cersei fighting for Cersei without her
kids to ground her with love is probably
just a very dangerous and horrific thing
can't wait to see it I do wonder Jaime
Lannister comes back Jaime lat I mean
Tommen was every bit his kid as much as
he was Cersei Lannisters kid but I
wonder if there's gonna be antitrust
between those two I wonder if Jamie's
gonna talk to Cersei at least once and
be like did you want Tommen to die or
did you not like were you hoping he
would kill himself so you could take the
throne tell me it's not true
just it has to be in his head he knows
she shrewd and conniving so I mean I
know like low Cersei is love is absolute
for her kids he would never think that
but he would it would at least cross his
mind so I want there to be at least a
little bit of antitrust there Cersei
getting that throne has caused her to
have a lot of enemies the Lannisters
have a lot of enemies now the Lannisters
are ruling the Seven Kingdoms now
Daenerys finally has her ships with some
Lannister enemies over there man they
got the Greyjoy's well at least a couple
of the Greyjoy's and some of the Greyjoy
is he hungry joined his sister got the
hell out of the iron Island
when their uncle came back killed her
father's lie right let's go kill those
two [ __ ] so they make a pact with
Daenerys Daenerys also makes a pact with
the Dornish folk I mean just a lot of
ships are coming to King's Landing
finally it's like yeah we've heard about
this [ __ ] for about five years now for
this half a decade of hearing about how
Daenerys is going to come to King's
Landing now she is on her way
barring something stupid happening like
they run into the Theon Greyjoy's
uncle's ships and they all get into a
big old ship skirmish and they go back
over there like all right we really got
her ass kicked we got to think about it
we got to regroup for another year learn
something dumb like that happening next
season they are going to land there's
going to be a battle a war a thing not
even including the fact that now once
again there is a divide because everyone
was like John Snow King in the North
King in the north like sorry Petyr
Baelish
not today funny thing is I love how they
brought in Benjen stark for like two
episodes say he comes in a like hey bran
I'm your uncle
piece all right I guess but among the
Jon Snow stuff they finally give the big
reveal of Jon Snow's lineage that was a
huge deal that was a big thing because
that's been a fan theory for a long time
I read the first book and only the first
book and it's an excellent book but even
reading that first game of Thrones book
you completely pick up on the nuance in
the book in book one where you like I
think Jon Snow's Lyanna stark and
rhaegar targaryen son and so that's the
big thing is that Lyanna stark had a kid
with Rhaegar Targaryen the sorry history
is written by the victors that is a
reality in stories and in life so the
story is Lyanna stark was kidnapped by
Rhaegar Targaryen and raped in realities
probably something along the lines of
Lyanna stark and rhaegar targaryen
probably just formed an actual
relationship and had a child Ned Stark's
the only one who knew and so he took
this kid on her behest she was like
don't tell Robert Baratheon because he
will kill him he's a Targaryen child
Robert Baratheon would absolutely kill
this kid so Ned Stark took it upon
himself to be like yeah I'm gonna wipe
my ass with my honour among everybody my
wife is gonna think I cheated on her
everyone's gonna be like Ned Stark to do
this totally horrible he has no honour
he's gonna do that for his sister's
child and her dying wish because he's
like I can't let anyone know that this
is a Targaryen kid he's going to be Jon
Snow and everyone will know him as my
bastard to be fair they kept it vague
and all you know is he's lyanna stark's
kid you don't know that he's right
targaryen skid but the fact that she was
like don't tell robert baratheon cuz
he'll kill him there's no other robert
baratheon would only want to kill one
kind of baby at that time and that would
be a Targaryen child now the king in the
north is a Targaryen which I find pretty
sweet I think next seasons going to be
the big battle where Daenerys is gonna
come in with her dragons like egg on
target there's a lot of Targaryen so
with Cersei Lannister gonna be like uh
Jon Snow's a problem up there while
she's fighting Daenerys and that whole
army is Jon Snow gonna be like hey
Daenerys why don't the two of us team up
because brans gonna come back and be
like hey Jon about your lineage
we're actually cousins but your aunt is
declaring war on the Lannisters we all
hate them too so let's just team up with
her so Targaryen is running the north
and the other Seven Kingdoms I feel like
that's gonna be next season and then the
final season is gonna be the huge like
White Walkers are coming down so they're
all gonna have to team up for that [ __ ]
too
but in the end it doesn't matter you
know why because it's like this that kid
just needs to give one speech to
everybody and she's like yeah now I'm
running [ __ ] everyone agrees all right
yeah Daenerys thank you for the crown
thank you for the throne thank you for
the three dragons you didn't have to
give those to me too but you did that's
what makes you great calling those White
Walkers and that whole invasion from the
north I took care of that like while I
was giving this speech little lady
Mormont she is awesome dude she is the
[ __ ] admittedly my favorite part of the
season finale this season finale had a
lot of cool stuff happen and as I'm
talking about I'm like wow this did have
a lot of cool stuff in this one episode
alone but my favorite part is probably
when Walder Frey's having his little
party and there's that girl who keeps
looking at Jaime Lannister you're like
oh she totally wants him totally right
then that girl did some Sweeney Todd
[ __ ] and slice up Walder Frey's kids and
made them pies and you're like oh -
Jaime Lannister hire this girl to kill
Walter freg has kind of gave him harsh
words earlier and she takes off her face
and she's like my name's Arya Stark and
I was like no way no [ __ ] way awesome
she kills Walder Frey out of there and
it's one of this what I like about this
is now the show is showing us that it's
finally happening
it being all of it everything we've
heard about we've heard that Daenerys is
gonna come over the sea and she's gonna
trade you to take King's Landing now
it's happening Arya Starks gonna get
revenge on these people that killed her
family now it's happening the build-up
is finally paying off and Arya killing
Walder Frey Matt it was just a really
gratifying moment that was
when I was like Oh Aria is gonna start
scratching names off of that list like
she's like Batman at this point she
learned from the League of Shadows
everything she needed to learn now she's
gonna go on her mission to do her thing
the bummers guys I think next season is
Cersei Lannisters last season with us I
don't think she's gonna make it through
that there's a lot of bad blood gonna
come clashing in the next season man you
got Tyrion Lannister fighting Cersei
Lannister Jaime Lannister caught in the
middle of all that [ __ ] Jaime Lannister
probably caught in the middle of Brienne
of Tarth who is up there with the Starks
they're friends but now they got to be
enemies or the frenemies now but it's
like frenemies to the death kind of [ __ ]
I mean next season should be nuts
so yeah this season the Game of Thrones
was crazy and I'm looking forward to
next season and I want to know what you
think about it so season six of Game of
Thrones
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more